I was gonna be talking about as well as
it is - I don't know we don't have to
come up
No yeah that's great that was a scene
from the 1996 little big night where
they serve these show-stopping Tim Pato
if you've ever wondered what that dish
tastes like your luck
YouTube sensation Andrew Reyes bringing
food from the big screen and from TV
right to your table in his youtube
series binging with babish jaime wax is
here with the story Jaime good morning
good morning Jeff Andrew ray started his
YouTube Series in 2016
three years later he's developed a huge
cult following online and published two
cookbooks including a New York Times
best seller I went into the kitchen with
him to talk about his recipe for success
I named the show completely arbitrarily
after an obscure character from The West
Wing and now it's my entire brand and
identity youtube series binging with
babish offers recipes rich in pop
culture add about half a cup of rum get
your torch ready and engage slow motion
he shows viewers how to replicate their
favorite on-screen meals in their homes
I humbly placed before you might
east-meets-west patented Traeger turkey
burger Parks and Rec came on and Ron and
Chris renting a burger cook-off here's
mine
it's a hamburger made out of meat on a
bun with nothing and it was like well if
that burger actually tastes like in real
life and oh I could try it right here
and with that binging with babish was
born at 20 ingredients that three hours
later I do not know how runs butter
who'd possibly stand up to oh it's way
better done it's not even a competition
is just better I only intended to make
the one people liked it I mean another
one people like that I made another one
and here we are now he has recreated
some of the most iconic meals in film
and television
down to every detail Vinnie was in
charge of the tomato sauce shaving
garlic with a razor blade for Goodfellas
prison sauce everybody is going to get
to know each other in the pot I'm
serious about the stuff
serving Kevin's chili from the office on
a piece of carpet tell me that is not
the most
thing you've ever seen this is ham
soaked in rum and even making the
downright disgusting rum ham from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia we're gonna
take a bite of it immediately spit out
because it's really really disgusting
that Ray now has two spinoff series and
two cookbooks a very common thread of
most youtubers is like I had no idea
that it would it would take off like
this
I really didn't I was deeply depressed
and in a I was not happy in my marriage
and I needed a creative outlet I just
wasn't happy in general a creative
outlet born of family memories my mother
taught me to cook when I was very young
she passed away when I was 11 and she
taught me how to make cookies she would
just go outside and get scoops of snow
and pour maple syrup over it and give it
to us and I just have a lot of very
specific food memories of my childhood
and it's one way that she gets to live
on and what I do and it's one way that I
get to feel a little closer to her she's
not his only influence it struck me your
mother Annie you love to cook your
father Douglas is a professor yes and
now you are teaching cooking yes do you
think that that's am I being too
analytical of you you're honestly making
me realize things I never thought I was
before like just like wow I really am my
parents kid it's like therapy we don't
need the camera we're gonna throw some
salt into the pot here when it comes to
YouTube stardom Ray's strives to
separate himself from the pack there's
definitely an element of narcissism in
establishing yourself as an online
personality you do need to be
self-absorbed in some ways and that was
something that I was trying to combat
with not showing my face I wanted to
make sure those purely about the food we
joined him behind the scenes to recreate
sliders from Harold and Kumar Go to
White Castle I want 30 sliders five
french fries and four large cherry cokes
I want the same exact make blind dine at
the cokes
so for scientific comparison because you
know accuracy is paramount to the show I
have some of these frozen sliders here
so we have a nice square little patty
yeah all right then
yeah very very thin that's why I want
away it's because I want to see exactly
what kind of target we're trying to hit
the whole idea with these burgers when
you cook them is that they steam on a
bed of
really yeah White Castle burgers never
hit the grill I gotta say I love how
well thought all of this stuff is it's
important to you to get this right yeah
I mean we want to make something that
resembles the foods from their favorite
fictions and then one of the hallmarks
of White Castle burgers so if they got
five holes punched in them this is
literally the first time you have tried
this process yes and you're shooting and
you're gonna use this and we are -
absolutely
and you're good with them yeah I love
that cuz if I screw it up I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you know where I went wrong
so people don't do the same thing at
home if they're crazy enough to try and
do this I got my buddy Jamie wax here
helping me out and we made just enough
burgers for the two of us an hour later
we made it official with a taste test
see how we did here mm-hmm that's really
good a solid burger and it's reminiscent
of White Castle it has the same kind of
flavor profile a bit can I have a few
for 3:00 a.m. so I could be sure that
they natural gasoline
nearly six million people tuned in to
Ray's channel and he asks just one thing
of them you don't like people to call
you chef I I didn't earn that title
there are people out there who really
went through the ringer and went to
culinary school and cut their teeth
under chefs that yelled and threw things
at them and I didn't I'm a home cook
that knows how to film and edit things
well my constant feeling with the
success of the show is I'm going to
continue to try and earn what you've
given me
binging with babish the cookbook is
available now and binging with babish
being with babish and basics with Babis
are available on youtube any time for
your binging pleasure yeah I could do
everything but that chili on the carpet
sorry the White Castle hadn't tastes
better than actual regular White Castle
I know it has this place I know some
people love them sorry you said it
tastes as he said I mean the beef was
really good the flavor profile is right
but it was it was definitely elevated
how to start watching him I love that
he's great and he has bigger presence
than so many established chefs online
it's amazing how how big is following
and no face no face I mean it doesn't
need it